schön dass ihr dabei seid zdf heute live
die bilder die täglich aus der ukraine
kommen daran kann und daran will man
sich nicht gewöhnen trotzdem werden sie
nicht weniger ein monatelanger kampf
inzwischen und manchmal hat man auch das
gefühl haben wir das gefühl es tut sich
wenig ist es still stand aber die
ukraine kämpft mit allem was sie hat
verteidigt sich und will vor allem jetzt
im süden und osten die von russland
besetzten gebiete zurückerobern doch
kann das dann kann das gelingen darum
geht es in dieser sendung heute wir
stellen diese frage einem experten wie
läuft die gegenoffensive um kassen und
wie könnte diese rückeroberung überhaupt
gelingen diese analyse die machen wir
später mit einem militärexperten mit dem
oberst ag wolfgang richter eure fragen
und kommentare jederzeit dazu im stream
oder direkt per mail aber beginnen
wollen wir unsere sendung mit eindrücken
ganz live von vor ort denn ein reporter
von uns ist vor ort und kann uns über
diese situation berichten denn immer
wieder dazu auch heute wieder
nachrichten was da gerade los ist im
süden und osten ein berater von
präsident sie denn ski der warnte heute
davor auf zu schnelle siege dort unten
zu hoffen es sei ein sehr langsamer
prozess sagte er auf den sich die
menschen dort einstellen müssen also ein
sehr langsamer prozess und vor allem ein
harter kampf gegen die russischen
kämpfer in den besetzten gebieten
wir haben aktuelle bilder von unserem
reporter und gänse hier aufgenommen vor
wenigen stunden in einem kleinen dorf
acht kilometer von der frontlinie
entfernt
wir sehen eine zerstörte schule in einem
kleinen dorf immer wieder attali feuer
ist zu hören in der region hier sehen
wir die schulbücher und in dem fall hat
es auch wieder gebäude betroffen in
denen eigentlich natürlich zu
friedenszeiten kinder unterrichtet
werden würden in denen ein friedliches
leben mal stattgefunden hat so nicht
mehr seit mehreren monaten wir sehen
jetzt unseren reporter und ginzel er ist
live für uns in mikulov hallo
hallo wir haben eben gerade die bilder
gesehen die duh heute aufgenommen hast
du hast natürlich auch mit den menschen
vor ort in der region gesprochen was
berichten sie dir von heute was ist los
in dieser region
ja seit dem kriegsausbruch ist natürlich
auch dieses tor genie
da heißt es
quasi schwer umkämpft und den ehemals
1200 einwohner sind noch im augenblick
muss man 18 200 quasi dort kinder haben
wir keine mehr gesehen
wahrscheinlichste sie schon längst mit
ihren eltern geflohen und die einwohner
die wir getroffen haben berichten von
täglichen
einschlägen artillerie von gefechten die
in der gegend stattfinden also seit
monaten gibt es sehr laut zu du stehst
gerade im hotel flur im hotel wo ihr
glaube ich auch die einzigen gäste im
moment seit dort wo er jetzt gerade ein
bisschen licht machen könnt entfernt von
den fenstern ansonsten ist die stadt
sehr dunkel und fast gespenstisch hast
du uns berichtet
ja also nikolov ist eigentlich eine sehr
große stadt im augenblick leben noch
zwei 250.000 menschen hier und wenn man
am tag sich das ansieht ja die stadt hat
auch den charakter einer großstadt aber
spätestens nach einbruch der dunkelheit
hat man das gefühl man ist irgendwie auf
dem land ich statt das absolut dunkel
es trennt keinen keine
straßenbeleuchtung die fenster sie mit
vorher zu oder sich das bereits
ausgeschaltet hier unser hotel man sieht
vielleicht es ist ganz spärlich
beleuchtet und die hotellobby ist fints
es ist dunkel der dümpelt noch irgendwie
nackt vor sich hin wir sind die einzigen
gäste wasser wird in großen
wasserflaschen her transportiert weil
das wasser was aus den rettung kommt
kann man nicht trinken auch nicht
zähneputzen oder irgendwas ist durch den
durch den krieg sind halt die leitungen
zerstört worden so dass im augenblick
noch wasser hier aus den leitungen kommt
das ist die situation die sich jetzt
darstellt
genau die situation in nicolai viertens
eben auch in einer karte gesehen nikolov
das liegt rund 80 kilometer nordwestlich
der von russland besetzten hafenstadt
ressort wird aber jetzt gerade noch von
der ukraine gehalten und laut der
ukraine wurde letzte nacht auch massiv
bombardiert so sagt die ukraine
russische raketen hätten dabei zwei
zivilisten getötet 24 weitere verletzt
was erwarten denn die bewohnerinnen und
bewohner für die kommende nacht du hast
ja heute auch mit einigen sprechen
können
also die menschen hier auf der straße
mit denen wir gesprochen haben die sagen
ja es findet halt jeden tag zu ganz
unterschiedlichen zeiten statt es gab
eine zeit da hast du machst du nach
mitternacht aber die karten das ist
unser 1 mit dieser gefahr
leben gelernt das klingt jetzt komisch
aber wir
hatten glaube ich letzthin nach 33
luftalarm am tag findet der stadt und
das ist völlig irre die menschen laufen
die dinge nach es guckt auch keiner mehr
zu reden hört co zehn bands und eine
detonation gibt aber die leute leben mit
dem luftalarm und mit der gefahr
permanent ja somit mit raketen
beschossen zu werden das ist jetzt im
augenblick so das häufigste das vor
einigen
raketeneinschlag in der großstadt es
sind also noch einige menschen dort aber
viele verlassen auch die region zumal
die regierung auch dazu aufgerufen hat
ganz deutlich zweimal die woche haben
wir hier gelesen bringen busse also
menschen in sicherheit aber wie würdest
du sagen gehen denn sehr viele oder
bleiben dann doch die allermeisten wie
er stellt sich das für dich da was hast
du gehört
also die menschen die jetzt noch da sind
ja sicher die werden sich überlegen ob
sie jeden werden aber es sind einfach
auch schon sehr viele gegangen also sind
schon 100.000 weg richtung usa oder in
andere orte die ihn sicher erscheint
viele sind nach untergegangen weil es
nicht sehr weit von hier und es gilt als
retter im augenblick als relativ sicher
[Musik]
ja es ist schwer abzuschätzen einige
leute sind in die wir haben heute mit
einwohnern gesprochen die wohnung in der
das
land gezogen wollen aber nicht richtig
weg
sind natürlich auch verbunden mit ihr
statt anders sieht das wirklich auf den
dörfern aus dort kann es durchaus sein
dass
auf den dörfern gibt es kein gas mehr da
gibt es auch kein wasser mehr versorgung
ich noch über 11 hinkommen und dazu
kommt eben noch der permanente geschoss
der hier stattfindet
werde ich sage wir waren heute 78
kilometer an der frontlinie
es läuft ja hier die offensive also das
führt natürlich dazu dass
kriegshandlungen stattfinden und mit ihm
zu diesen kriegshandlungen letzten endes
noch dazu kommt dass menschen nicht zu
essen zu trinken haben nicht heizen
können dann entsteht natürlich nochmal
ein massiver druck also ich denke dass
von den dörfern die die noch geblieben
sind da wird es noch einige geben lieber
kindern es treibt auch natürlich jetzt
einige die bislang ausgeharrt haben in
dieser situation dazu zu gehen wir haben
ein paar stimmen gesammelt aus nikolov
und einmal kurz zusammen rein
ich bin lange nicht fort gegangen weil
mein mann hier kurz vor kriegsausbruch
gestorben ist ich habe ihn beerdigt es
ist hart zugehen wenn ein mensch der
einem so nahe stand hier beerdigt liegt
[Musik]
ich denke ich werde nach odessa gehen
ich kann dort umsonst unterkommen
ich habe mich heute entschieden zu gehen
wegen dem häufigen beschuss es ist zu
meiner eigenen sicherheit ich möchte
tiermedizin studieren und das in frieden
jetzt bringe ich auch meine haustiere in
sicherheit
das angesprochen es sind nicht nur die
kriegerischen handlungen die die
menschen dazu treiben zu gehen sondern
die regierung hat auch ganz stark
geraten dass menschen jetzt eben vor
beginn der kälteren jahreszeit die
region verlassen du hast es auch
angesprochen große probleme mit
wärmeversorgung strom und wasser werden
befürchtet gerade jetzt natürlich wenn
es kälter wird aber die dann jetzt also
noch bleiben auch angesichts dieser herr
dieser zukunft was berichten sie dir
glauben sie an einen schnelleren sieg
auch wenn die regierung selbst sagt das
wird also lange dauern macht euch auf
eine lange zeit gefasst
ehrlich gesagt mit denen einwohnern mit
denen wir heute gesprochen haben für die
war das gar nicht so
relevant also für sich für diese erst
mal egal ob es dann auch dosenbier gibt
oder was auch immer sie
sie haben sich quasi an fronten hier
eingerichtet und im keller wenn wenn die
granaten fliegen
natürlich klar die hoffen dass ist das
ist wieder friedlich wird dass sie in
ihren dörfern leben können aber
ich glaube das ist jetzt nämlich spürbar
für die menschen die in diesen gebieten
in diesem umkämpften gebieten leben
meine wir haben heute mit dem leben
heute auch mit militär gesprochen hier
in nicolai es mit der
militäradministration hier vor ort die
machen halt eine rechnung auf die sagen
ja von oder aus betrachtet musterklagen
ein buch geschrieben haben ist die
frontlinie 20 km entfernt
der song ist 60 kilometer entfernt sind
es ja nur noch in anführungsstrichen 40
kilometer die wir treffen müssen so
einfach ist die sache natürlich
denke ich also das was wir gesehen haben
wir sind die regel 8 von 8 mm oder
frontlinie dass das da wird noch
unkenntnis da wird gekämpft wir sehen
dort artillerie die zwischen den dörfern
oft gestellt ist wir sehen wir sehen
raketenwerfer die wir haben es mit
eigenen augen gesehen die raketen
abgefeuert werden dann werden wird die
artillerie umgesetzt damit der gegner in
dem fall eben die russische armee die
artillerie nicht orten und zerstören
kann dort ist bewegung und das da sind
echte kampfhandlungen im augenblick und
insofern denkt da glaube ich jetzt noch
keiner an den tag an den personen
befreit ist oder an dem tag an dem es
irgendwie ruhiger geworden ist ja
überhaupt nicht ruhiger du hast das uns
schon berichtet haben den ersten bildern
gesehen haben die zerstörte schule
gesehen du hast aber auch noch weiteres
erlebt einen zerstörten kindergarten
hast du gesehen was ja was ist noch
passiert was du bezeugen konntest
gesehen hast du gestern am nachmittag
wir sind gestern hier angekommen und es
gelungen dann doch auch raus aus der
stadt zu fahren obwohl es im augenblick
journalisten unheimlich schwierig ist
die
die armee hat im prinzip die gebiete
abgeriegelt für journalisten einen
augenblick warum auch immer
trotzdem sind wir gestern raus gefahren
und haben gesehen ja wir militärkonvois
stehen an einer
auf einer straße haben wir sanitäts züge
gesehen die waren sehr gut vorbereitet
darunter waren auch viele einsatzwagen
aus deutschland die dort über die die
ukrainische armee verfügt die ligen
waren alle nebeneinander aufgestellt
also wirklich für den für den fall der
fälle dass dort verwundete soldaten
ankommen das fand ich schon
beeindruckend einerseits ja auch
verwunderlich dass das alles noch so
nach einem blick sehr viel
stattfindet ich hätte gedacht wir sind
schon ein stück weiter aber
man sieht man sieht kampfhandlungen ich
glaube die nie die nehmen das sehr ernst
zugehen wollen richtung erst und die
wollen wirklich befreiend das ist unser
eindruck mein eindruck
es gibt fragen aus dem stream an dich
einer hast du eigentlich eben schon
beantwortet er wollte bastian steffen
wissen guten abend herr gen c d frey
können sie sich in der ukraine bewegen
und filmen passen sie auf sich auf da
hattest du eben schon angesprochen dass
es schwierig ist aber ihr natürlich
versucht es trotzdem euch zu bewegen so
viel ihr könnt das habe ich so richtig
verstanden oder ja also wir haben ja
sehr gute kollegen mit denen wir
unterwegs sind die die die stadt aber
auch die region drumherum kennen wir
wären auch sehr gut betreut von von
deutschland aus das funktioniert alles
sehr gut weil das wissen um die um die
veränderten
konfliktlinien die sind halt
existenziell für uns also da als nicht
statisch das wechsel durch schon
deswegen
das weißt du hörst ist der ist der sind
die bilder von der zerstörten schule und
des zerstörten kindergarten sondern
generell das von den zerstörten regionen
damit gerade mal bilder gezeigt wenn du
sprichst die armee versucht versucht
schon das ist schon mein eindruck schon
sichtweise zu vermitteln beim ist
natürlich ein stück weit abhängig aber
es gibt halt immer wieder auch wenige
wie man
sich frei bewegen kann und auch
eindrücke sammeln kann dass das muss ich
auch sagen es gibt
lücken system so also man kann durchaus
als journalist hier arbeiten und
aber wir haben gemerkt dass es den
letzten wochen hier doch durchaus
restriktiver zu geht also in anderen
gebieten um satte beispielsweise rom gab
es für einige tage betretungsverbot von
stimmt auch ortschaften für journalisten
warum auch immer und
mittlerweile ist das wieder offen
mittlerweile kam auch dort als im netz
wieder arbeiten aber es gibt durchaus
mal zeit immer wieder zeiten wo man
schwierigkeiten und sagt man ja er sei
aus sicherheitsgründen aber
wir arbeiten ja auch in anderen gegenden
den haag es beispielsweise
klarer ist die sicherheitslage sind
überall irgendwie etwas unterschiedlich
aber militär allgemein halt immer
natürlich das interesse zu
die informationswege zu kanalisieren und
da müssen wir versuchen als journalistin
unsere wege zu suchen und zu finden über
das quasi und anrufen claudia mondorf
ski schreibt herzlichen dank an arndt
ginzel und sein team passen sie auf sich
auf das sollte natürlich gerne wissen
und zum schluss ich ja bitte und zum
schluss aber auch noch eine frage aus
dem stream und zwar von norbert kranz
der sich fragt wie stark ist die
unterstützung der bevölkerung
beziehungsweise der partisanen in den
besetzten gebieten gegen die russen habt
ihr da schon erfahrungen gemacht etwas
gehört ja
wir haben heute mit einem mann
gesprochen der
in der vergangenheit
zwar nicht als partisan sondern als
bürgermeister einer eines ortes
wie sondern sagen hinter den feindlichen
linien
die ukrainische armee in von montag
beispielsweise überstellung nun also
befinden sich russische soldaten
hat diese information an die ukraine
weiter gewissheit später haben die
russische armee ihn festgenommen wurde
gefoltert es frei gekauft und diese wege
diese netzwerke funktionieren doch haben
wir heute auch kann man sagen wir wissen
ja ein herr song gibt es menschen die
ganz aktiv die ukrainische armee
unterstützen das amt über unsere kanäle
heute ab haben wir wollen auch dran
bleiben weil ich das auch für ein sehr
spannendes thema halte für die nächsten
tage
morgen gewinnt er die möglichkeit mit
dem mann zu sprechen wer beispielsweise
mit einer privaten drohne ebenfalls
geflogen ist und russische stellung an
die
ukrainische armee weitergeleitet hat
also es gibt es
und ich glaube auch dass die armee die
ukrainische armee darauf angewiesen ist
sagt arndt ginzel der für uns heute
abend eindrücke aus nicolai direkt vor
ort geliefert hat vielen dank dafür
gerne danke tschüss und
wir haben es angesprochen am anfang der
sendung wir wollen jetzt auch noch mal
analytisch auf den krieg dort schauen es
geht ja vor allem um die rückeroberung
von carson am dienstag hatte das büro
von präsident zine sg schwere kämpfe in
fast dem gesamten gebiet so hieß es
gemeldet und wie diese rückeroberung der
besetzten gebiete aber wirklich gelingen
kann darüber können wir jetzt sprechen
mit dem militärexperten oberst ag
wolfgang richter der uns jetzt
zugeschaltet ist schönen guten abend
herr richter schön kunden freuen herr
richter die ukraine die meldet die
zerstörung von mehreren russischen
munitionsdepots das hätten sie geschafft
und auch fast alle brücken hätten sie
zerstört über dem fluss mit dem ipro
können sie das so bestätigen
bei allen informationen die ich selber
habe es den ukraine und tatsächlich
gelungen diese brücken es geht um drei
wesentliche brücken weitgehend
auszuschalten so wenn die so schwer zu
beschädigen dass kein schwerer lasten
verkehre über diese brücken kommt das
hat auch dazu geführt dass die kosten
versucht haben mit kontrollpunkten
reguläre zu arbeiten um das um einen
minimum sicherzustellen von logistik und
die wirkung ist klar die ukraine
versuchen reserven der ruß und die sie
nach westen bringen wollen über den
fluss oder auch logistik dort
abzusperren abzuriegeln und damit sie
dann ungestörter
westlich des flusses ihre offensive
fahren können der punkt war eigentlich
immer in der vergangenheit auch schon
dass man solche schläge in der tiefe
ausnutzen muss für bewegung da scheint
jetzt gestartet zu sein aber wie wir
schon von am kindle gehört haben jetzt
diese bewegung natürlich zunächst einmal
langsam ist finden immer noch in erster
linie artilleriegefechte stadt und die
front verläuft relativ
mal noch an nikolai wir haben gehört
etwa 20 km das wird natürlich sich etwas
verändern jeden tag aber bis nach
personen sind es gut 40 kilometer und
dann kommt ja eigentlich wenn man an
befreiung denkt kann es ja zunächst mal
nur um das teilstück gehen das westlich
des neckar liegt denn auch für die
ukrainische armee selbst wenn sie das
schaffen würde wäre die stadt selbst ein
großes hindernis also kann es aber auch
der fluss denn die brücken haben sie ja
gerade zerstört das heißt das
maximalziel der gegenwärtigen offensive
kann nur richtung fluss gehen und wenn
wir müssen das tun was die ukraine
vorher getan haben nämlich die rollen
jetzt wechseln carson verteidigen und
dann möglichst wir das haus und jeden
stein dann wird es erstens ein sehr
langwieriger kampf es wird sehr blutig
werden und die stadt wird dann auch zum
großen teil zerstört werden denn auch
den ukrainer bleibt ja dann nichts
anderes über als ich mit artillerie vor
zu boxen und das ist wohl auch der
hintergrund warum die ukrainische
führung die bevölkerung aufgerufen hat
zu fliehen das können sie übrigens nur
nach osten also oder süden das heißt in
richtung russisch besetzte gebiete
schauen wir uns das auch noch mal hier
auf der interaktiven live karte an die
könnt ihr euch auch alle im netz
anschauen da sieht man die
kampfhandlungen eingezeichnet und ich
suche ein bisschen genauer an dass wir
auch mal diese region carson über die
weder sprechen noch mal genauer sehen
können und vielleicht auch mehr
verstehen was daran so wichtig ist die
strategische bedeutung wo die stadt also
liegt hier sehen wir sie und die stadt
liegt eben grenzt an die von 2014 von
russland annektierte schwarzmeer
halbinsel krim das ist natürlich brisant
und moment gesehen wir hier genug ich
hoffe doch und als erste großstadt war
in der ukraine barkassen anfang märz
eben kurz nach kriegsbeginn von der
russischen armee eingenommen worden und
die region ist auch ausland
wirtschaftlichen gründen für die region
von zentraler bedeutung und eben auch
die strategischen er hier zur krim ist
von bedeutung also hier sehen wir das
nochmal und ihr könnt übrigens auch auf
dieser karte hier anklicken was quasi
als raketen symbol eingezeichnet ist
oder hier als panzer symbol
eingezeichnet ist beschuss ist hier
eingezeichneten dann seht ihr rechts
hier an der seite immer auch eine
erklärung dazu also wen das interessiert
der kann dann natürlich auch selbst mal
reinschauen jetzt haben wir alle mehr
einen eindruck von der region wo sie
auch in die wiso denn diese
rückeroberung von versauen so schwierig
ja es ist natürlich deswegen schwierig
weil insgesamt vom kriegsbeginn an die
russischen streitkräfte eine
überlegenheit an kräften hatten und eine
überlegenheit an
luftstreitkräften insbesondere
es mangelt den ukraine nicht an personal
aber es ist natürlich so dass er
russland sehr viele reserven
nachschieben kann das tun sie derzeit
sie versuchen bei den gegenangriff
sozusagen gegen den angriff
einzuführen in denen sie reserven von
der krim oder auch über den korridor von
don was nach osten nach westen schieben
um dann einen gegen schwerpunkt zu
bilden ob ihnen das gelingt dann muss
man natürlich sehen denn sie werden dann
auch schwierigkeiten haben über den mehr
platz bekommen aber es gibt dann immer
noch einige möglichkeiten wie man das
bewerkstelligen kann und kann es
versuchen übertrieb schraubern
hinzukriegen mit pioneer mit kompon
brücken oder mit der ausbesserung der
beschädigten brücken aber es wird sehr
schwierig für russland werden das zu tun
wie gesagt die ukraine können
jetzt ist kalt die verbindung zu herrn
richter unterbrochen haben sie mich sehr
wieder und wir haben jetzt auch wieder
ein bild
da ist die internetverbindung instabil
jetzt ist wieder alles fein gar kein
problem sein gut ich weiß nicht wie weit
sie mich gehört haben aber es wird
wahrscheinlich darauf hinauslaufen dass
die frage sich am ende wieder stellen
wird wer kann mehr reserven und
schneller wir saßen in diesen raum
hinein führen die luftüberlegenheit die
ja eigentlich zugunsten russlands
ausschlagen musste konnte russland
bisher nicht
konnte russland bisher nicht haben wir
gehört falls der richter gleich wieder
konnte russland bisher nicht bis dahin
habe gehört sie konnte bisher die luft
verschafft nicht herstellen trotz
luftüberlegenheit und das ist natürlich
das bedeutet auch eine gewisse operation
freiheit für die ukrainische seite die
luftverteidigung der ukraine drückt
immer noch und damit können sie sich im
prinzip auch an bord bewegen ob sie eine
großoffensive hinbekommen in der ja
viele kräfte feuer und bewegung
koordiniert werden muss wir müssen das
haben wir bisher zumindest noch nicht
erlebt aber wir werden sehen ob sie das
schaffen und wir werden dann sehen wie
schnell die russen sind
reserven heranzuführen um einen gegen
schwerpunkt zu bilden und ob die ukraine
wiederum in der lage sind mit ihren
neuen weitreichenden waffen das
heranführen diese reserven zu
unterbinden es gibt einige fragen an sie
auch aus dem stream und zwar einmal von
century seventy seven er oder sie möchte
wissen nachdem beim angriff der russen
schon viel an infrastruktur zerstört
wurde ist dann ein tiefer vorstoß
logistisch überhaupt möglich momentan
sind nur kleine gewinne über einen
langen zeitraum möglich es wird
sicherlich so sein dass es im moment nur
langsam vorangehen wird dass die
ukrainer sind vor allem den gut darin
taktische gegenstöße zu machen also im
kleineren rahmen örtlich begrenzt
vorstöße zu machen da haben sie nicht
nur große kampf moral bewiesen sondern
auch ein ausgezeichnetes taktisches
geschick ist jetzt jedenfalls das kann
natürlich zu ihren gunsten ausschlagen
aber man muss dann unterscheiden
zwischen örtlichen vor stößen und einer
großen strategischen gegenoffensive das
sind völlig andere dinge man gern noch
nicht gesehen dass die ukraine in der
lage sind diese kräfte zu massieren die
man dafür braucht und dann auch feuer
bewegung und der kräfte so zu
koordinieren dass große räume genommen
wird also wie die ukrainische regierung
selber ja einen chefs und ich schließe
mich dem auch völlig an wird das noch
ganz ganz langsam vorangehen und was die
zerstörung betrifft die fand mir im
süden weniger stadt als etwa im möglich
von kiew oder im osten insbesondere im
don was ich glaube die infrastruktur
fragen stellen sich hier nicht so hart
wie etwa in diesen ämtern ostgebieten
aber es wird die frage wird für die
bevölkerung zu stellen sein was passiert
denn wenn ein großer gegenangriff der
sehr starke feuer beruht jetzt auf
dörfer und städte hereinprasselt und das
da muss ja die bevölkerung geschützt
sein das geht ja noch über schutzräume
oder über evakuierung und das ist der
hintergrund der aufforderung der
ukrainischen regierung die bevölkerung
möge doch fliegen und macht nach osten
und süden ausweichen ja die
pressesprecherin des südkommandos der
ukrainischen armee die spricht von
sogenannten positionskämpfen die also
stattfinden in nicolai fund saison sind
das jetzt aber wie kann man das
einschätzen sind es nur kleine
nadelstiche die die ukraine da erreicht
oder ist das schon was größeres was es
da ihre einschätzung es sind natürlich
mehr ist norderstedt sind taktische
faktische vorstöße wollte herr richter
wahrscheinlich sagen wir wissen ja jetzt
schon er ist auch irgendwann wieder bei
uns deswegen packen das gehört sowie für
diese in stabile verbindung es ist wohl
so dass wir mit taktischen vorstößen im
moment zu rechnen haben dass diese
praktischen vorstöße auch in der lage
sind aber in sehr kleinen schritten
gelände zu nehmen aber das ist so das
gilt doch für dorf- oder es gibt
natürlich auch wieder rückschläge es
gibt sehr sehr langsam voran und
das dann
es gibt sehr langsam voran ich glaube ja
wir warten jetzt natürlich noch mal die
antwort von herrn richter ab der jetzt
gleich wieder bei uns ist so hoffen wir
zumindest prof sie dachten es geht sehr
langsam voran es geht sehr langsam voran
schritt für schritt das ist so weil
diesen praktischen vorgehen dass immer
nur kleine räume betrifft zu mir glaube
ich kann kann die ukrainische armee auch
im moment nicht die kraft aufbringen
aber dennoch sage ich nicht dass das
nicht auch gelingen kann wenn man muss
dann eben eine große geduld haben und es
muss weiter dann auch so sein dass man
von ukrainischer seite her dass die
logistik der osten und auch das
heranbringen von reserven abwickelt dazu
haben sie ja waffen die in die tiefe
wirken und die wurden ja bisher auch
schon genutzt weil unsere verbindung
nicht die beste ist würde ich jetzt zum
schluss eine frage noch stellen weil wir
natürlich sorge haben dass ich das jetzt
nicht besser aber das finde ich noch
sehr spannend denn die usa haben heute
das finde ich interessant gemeldet also
das pentagon sie sehen also die
fortschritte des ukraine militärs
gegenüber russland zitat und sind
ukrainische militär operation bekannt
die eine gewisse vorwärtsbewegung
gemacht haben und aus der region person
wissen wir dass russische einheiten in
einigen fällen zurückfallen das sagte
die penta der pentagon sprecher wie
steht denn russland im vergleich zur
ukraine wirklich da ich glaube darüber
müssen wir auf jeden fall noch mal
sprechen
weißrussland hat gerade in den ersten
phasen des krieges hohe verluste
hinnehmen müssen weil sie eine
fehleinschätzung über die ukrainische
widerstandskraft erlegen sind das haben
sie mittlerweile korrigiert sie sind
jetzt wieder dabei das zu tun was sie
schon traditionell immer gemacht haben
mit viel artillerie einsatz auf
kleinstem raum schwerpunkte zu bilden um
sich dann langsam nach vorne zu boxen
was am 7 was gemacht das tun sie doch
weiterhin im süden und auch in carson da
haben sie sich eher auf die verteidigung
zurückgezogen sie haben versucht die
lage zu stabilisieren und haben dort
bisher keine schwerpunkte gebildet das
kann sich aber ändern russland ist aus
meiner sicht zumindest die
landstreitkräfte russland sind
strategische über den
sind strategisch überlegen
wahrscheinlich wir lassen ja ein richter
diese antwort auf jeden fall natürlich
noch beenden das ist heute ein bisschen
wackelig mit der verbindung das passiert
manchmal und versuche mal gern aus sind
strategisch überlegen hatte gegenüber
den tat ich gesagt über den überdehnt ja
ja sie haben also relativ viel kräfte in
der ukraine eingesetzt und können aber
nicht alle kräfte von einem anderen
langen grenzen russlands abziehen da
gibt's ja noch mehr hotspots das ist der
hintergrund warum die russische
regierung jetzt ein gesetz verabschiedet
hat um etwa 137 1000 soldaten und
soldatinnen mehr einzuziehen das heißt
die kräfte zu verstärken daran kann man
erkennen was ihnen natürlich auch die
kräfte dünn werden und dass die
mannschaft schwierigkeiten haben zwei
oder drei schwerpunkte in der ukraine
gleichzeitig zu bilden einmal natürlich
der dom bass das ist klar da wird man
weitermachen aber auch der versuch jetzt
einen gegen schwerpunkt zu bilden gegen
die ukrainische gegen offensive im raum
das ist glaube ich der hintergrund
dieser russischen maßnahmen
russland insgesamt muss ich sagen hat
mit seinen landstreitkräften nicht die
erwartungen erfüllt die viele
militärexperten in diese streitkräfte
gesetzt haben sie waren ja immer sehr
modern ausgerüstet und zumindest bei
paraden gut anzusehen aber die
tatsächliche leistung und kampf hat noch
etwas erstaunt und die ukraine machen
deswegen doch obwohl sie insgesamt ja
nicht überlegen sein sondern unterlegen
sind machen durchaus an eine sehr gute
arbeit sie sind moralische gelegen und
sie sind auch praktisch gut aufgestellt
was das gefechte der verbundenen waffen
betrifft
sagt militärexperte oberst adi wolfgang
richter vielen dank für ihre
einschätzung heute abend gerne frau jo
und tut mir leid was die
internetverbindung wird von 10 statt wie
das passiert ganz genau das passiert und
ihr könnt euch aber sicher sein dass wir
leider natürlich bestimmt auch wieder
auf dieses thema schauen in den nächsten
tagen und dann gibt sich bestimmt auch
noch mal die möglichkeit die fragen zu
beantworten für die wir jetzt hier
keinen platz mehr hatten aber bis
hierhin erstmal vielen dank für eure
aufmerksamkeit dass ihr dabei wart gerne
nächstes mal wieder